c'était il ya un mois jour pour jour
aujourd'hui tout le québec doit se
mettre en mode d'urgence le 12 mars le
premier ministre convoque une première
conférence de presse les québécois
l'ignorent encore mais leur vie
s'apprête à changer du tout au tout on
est dans une crise qui va durer des mois
un geste à la fois l'étau se resserre on
force les voyageurs à s'isoler
on interdit les rassemblements on ferme
les écoles les cégeps et les universités
pourront s'organiser parce que là nous
on essaie de travailler en même temps
la situation est particulièrement
difficile pour les aînés qui vivent en
résidence
on n'interdit d'abord les visites envoyé
à maison avant d'interdire aussi les
sorties bâillements
le nombre de personnes atteintes
continue d'augmenter il faut agir vite
le 14 mars ont déclaré l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
de nombreux québécois cherchent à se
faire tester mais l'accès au dépistage
est difficile il va être réglé ce
problème là aujourd'hui même le 23 mars
le premier ministre annonce un quasi
confinement tous les commerces et toutes
les entreprises jugées non essentielles
doivent fermer leurs portes mon mail
québec sur pause la nouvelle fait mal
des centaines de milliers de québécois
se retrouvent au chômage du jour au
lendemain le travail peu d'argent qui
rentre de cinq endroits d'amazon
défilent apparaissent devant les
commerces toujours ouverts chaque visite
à l'épicerie doit compter banal ça
risque de la plus grande bataille de
notre vie la transmission communautaire
s'étend progressivement à tout le
territoire pour freiner le virus ont
restreint l'accès aux régions éloignées
des barrages policiers font leur
apparition le long des routes
pendant ce temps dans les hôpitaux ont
frôlé la pénurie de masse on en or pour
trois à sept jours
québec dévoile ses prévisions on pense
pouvoir atteindre le sommet de la courbe
dans les prochains jours le déplacement
de la courbe dans le temps aulas cathy
il faut garder espoir répète le premier
ministre même si la vie ne sera plus
comme avant
encore un bon moment ici hugo lavallée
radio canada québec